in last week's vfx artist react video we
talked about the muzzle flashers and
john wick and how they're not an
accurate representation of real muzzle
flashes they serve the purpose of the
movie but i think we can improve them i
think we can make them better because
that's one of the things we do here at
corridor fake guns
[Music]
now this is not going to be quite as
crazy of a change as a scorpion king
instead what you're going to see is us
taking an artistry and craft that we
have spent years honing we're going to
try to make them more accurate to real
life muscle flashes would it be an
improvement would it be unnoticeable
what does matter in the world of action
and what subtle things can make a
difference you will see some scenes from
john wick with the gun effects
completely redone by us and you let us
know if you think it's an improvement
it's time to get to work
are you a fan of john wick i love john
wick dude me too i love it amazing
choreography those gun effects i just i
don't think they look all that great
here's the first house fight
the most important thing is the burst of
light and they're getting that
the exposure of the muzzle flashes feels
off like i feel like they need to be
more blown out they're shooting in
almost complete darkness yeah i mean the
gun handling is great
we do a lot of action videos here at
corridor especially with guns we've been
doing gun videos for a long time we've
hired real guns for various videos we've
done blank powering guns for various
videos and we've done a lot of cg muzzle
flashes because when you're on set both
real guns and blank firing guns tend not
to be too practical the thing is blank
firing guns are actually dangerous
because you're still ejecting a ton of
force from the front of the pistol now
we talked about this in our visual
effects artists react episode that went
up last week but when you're at this
close quarters you can't use a blank
firing gun because it can actually hurt
and kill the person in front of you with
just that muzzle explosion so for these
close quarter combat scenes they're
using barrel plugged blank guns
functionally very similar to a gas
blowback airsoft gun and they're adding
the effects afterwards of the gunshots
thanks to our experience doing it for
real we know what it should look like so
let's break it down frame by frame for a
second here we have a muzzle flash and
we have some fake lighting being added
to the scene you know they're kind of
lightening up the people around it but
the fake lighting is only right here you
know the side of this guy's not getting
hit with light the background here is
not really getting hit with light
there's no shadow of like john wick on
the background and in the second frame
there's just a weird half transparent
muzzle flash that's not what happens in
real life when you film blank firing
guns you shouldn't have a big puff of
fire with another half transparent
smaller puff of fire as if the gun's
inhaling the muzzle flash back into it
this is like one of the most common
errors with muzzle flashes is having it
stick to the gun
like
it came out here the gun's moving but
the air the expanding gases that are the
muzzle flash are there in front and that
they're not parented with the gun they
would stay where they were initially i
mean we don't know that he's not firing
a fully auto pistol
he's fine you just right on two shots
off really fast there's also no smoke
coming out of these guns and it's one of
the things that really sells the power
of the gun that shows you those
expanding gases those forces that are
ejecting that little piece of metal out
of the gun because in real life if you
shoot a pistol within a third of a
second so smoke from the muzzle flash
will have ejected out about six feet the
smoke from a muzzle flash is what gives
a gun its power and by not having the
smoke and these things with john wick
they're missing a huge portion of what
could really make these muzzle flashes
hit hard actually the thing that bugs me
when i
watch this scene
is the sound design to be honest if you
listen to it you hear the zips and zaps
that actually sounds closer to what an
airsoft pistol sounds like yeah than a
real gun
so that's literally just the sound of
the mechanical elements and so when
you're listening to in the scene you can
just
hear that happening no gunshots you're
gonna go back a few frames let's just
make sure we know gunny's using um that
looks like an hk something with an
extended compensator wow sam with the
gun trivia okay so it's not a suppressor
it shouldn't be going
i want to feel the effect of the sound
of these guns filling every corner of
the room let's do a quick demonstration
so pay attention not to the initial bang
because that lasts for a frame pay
attention to the tail of the sound but
if everyone just shuts up after it
explodes you'll hear it yeah fire in the
hole
got nailed in the foot peter you're
supposed to shut up
i got nails pick two bar in the hole
tail is a lot shorter but it's got that
boominess so it's hard to describe what
the frick is boominess
it's like it's like imagine a
marshmallow exploding
really hard
[Laughter]
i gotta imagine that
yeah
all right so let's see if we can make
john wick even better let's see if we
can fix the muggle flashes and try some
things in the sound design to really
make these guns feel powerful
what are you doing i'm trying to get in
the shot so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to start with a couple scenes let
me erase the second muzzle flash that's
there for a second frame and put our
muzzle flash elements in there i'm going
to try to adjust the lighting i'm going
to add smoke i'm going to add camera
bloom
what are you do i don't know but uh it's
gonna be sick
all right how about you sam what i'm
thinking is i'm actually gonna snag some
of these firecrackers record them that's
gonna make the whole thing way more
punchier it's gonna it's gonna really
transform the scene the guns sound
different as well as look different
let's do it
hello hey guys it's john here hey jake
how are you hey since everyone is trying
to make the muzzle flashes in my movie a
little bit better i thought i'd come in
here and offer everyone a little bit of
advice on how today's sponsor
squarespace can make your lives better
how's that sound guys
sounds good
hey guys john here what are you working
on now so you don't have a problem in
the future making sure our robot is
rigged up in unity well guess what with
squarespace you can make one post on
your squarespace website and that'll
post automatically on all those profiles
it's like twitter facebook and tumblr
also it's optimized so you don't have to
worry about the titles not fitting or
the number of words you're using not
working you should consider that
next time you do a presentation
definitely get this done consider that
i'm john you're working again i'm always
working i'm retired how do you know that
what are you working on we're fixing
your movie do you know who's gonna own
this video at the end of the day
corridor digital well with squarespace
they offer 100 content ownership meaning
that all the stuff that you put onto
your squarespace website you own so
we'll own this video
i hope so if you decide you don't want
to use squarespace one day they offer
one-click portability meaning that you
get all that information right back to
you what are you working on sam you know
i'm just working trying to get this
robot working in real time in unity for
a cigarette presentation how many people
are going to work on this robot with you
no one i work alone it would probably be
really helpful if you worked with other
people that's so true and so that's
what's great about squarespace
squarespace offers multiple contributors
to the same website also you can toggle
access meaning that if you don't like
that guy over there tell them hey guess
what you can't actually have that
permission but but you can your robot is
going to work thank you beautiful it's
going to work yeah it's going to be
great now i'm psyched uh jake's dressed
up like john wick he's coming over here
let's go along with it oh god yeah say
what are you working on i'm just kind of
doing something squarespace offers you
traffic oversight on any of your
websites meaning that if you need to
know who comes to your website where
they come from squarespace can tell you
that super useful actually you might
have to check that out so if you're
interested in starting your own
squarespace just go to
just go to squarespace.com corridor crew
and you'll get 10 off your first
purchase is your leg okay
that's
i'm working on it hold on guys i'll be
right back jake's being weird today dude
yeah
so like what they're using it's kind of
like 80s drums gated reverb drums
because they have a normal gun sound
effect where it goes
they're cutting it off short so it goes
they're not using indoor samples they're
using like gun on the range sound
effects it's my goal to fix that so i'm
just going to do a quick little audio
pass here to punch it up a bit two
things one get some custom explosion
fully using some firecrackers and then
i'm also going to dig into my sound
packs touch it up a little bit
let's pull subscribe
i'm gonna record a firecracker here
don't be alarmed
okay let's do that again but don't use
the next time
that was way too loud
fire all right ready everyone's
fire in the hole
i don't need the the pop
so much i need everything after the pop
the thing is is that when it explodes
everyone needs to be totally quiet or
else it's unusable
stop walking
i'm sorry
find the hole
nailed it thanks guys let me put out all
the fires
best smell takes me to my happy place to
be entirely honest like that sulfur
smell is this like bottle rocket fights
4th of july all sorts of shenanigans
well sam's blowing subscribe uh i'm
sitting here working on the effects for
this shot so here's the raw scene i'm
gonna focus on one muzzle flash here
this one that this guy shoots right here
muzzle flashes don't just move stuck to
the end of the gun once they come out
the gun that's where it comes out of
it's like blowing smoke you know you can
move your mouth but the smoke stays
where you blew it out
not to mention it's kind of fading out
and looking weird in the second frame
and muzzle flashes only exist for one
frame so the very first thing i have to
do is i have to erase the second muzzle
flash and here we have that
so the next thing i did is i added one
of our muzzle flash elements that we
filmed ourselves out in the desert from
an actual pistol so a couple interesting
things to point out here you can see a
really bright point where it's coming
out of the gun you can see sparks the
sparks continue for a couple of frames
that element brings a lot of light i'm
taking this muzzle flash and putting it
on top of the other muzzle flash for the
very first frame their base muzzle flash
isn't that bad but it's missing some of
these details and that's what i'm
bringing back in with mine it also
doesn't just stick to the gun
arbitrarily that'd look really weird so
the next thing the most
important thing in my opinion is the
smoke smoke gives guns their punch back
in the day we were filming sync
we needed some smoke for our muzzle
flashes and so we got an air compressor
and some flour and we shot the flower
out of an air compressor and then we
ramped the footage so you get more
acceleration at the beginning and that
burst coming out of the gun works so
well for showing the power of a gun
there it is boom the smoke should be
about twice the length of the muzzle
flash based on all my studying of actual
gun shooting and it should move at a
pretty good speed all right so now that
we have our flash and our smoke in there
the last thing i need to do is add some
fake lighting so there's already a
little bit of fake lighting in this
scene but it feels a little dark like
this the wall behind the guy should be
lit up the wall below keanu's arm should
be lit up and i'm going to brighten them
myself and when everything is said and
done you get something kind of like this
[Music]
you can see the smoke you can see the
sparks looks pretty good and pretty
punchy kind of bob rossing some muzzle
flashes here for you guys happy little
flair yeah this is like one of my
biggest pet peeves i'm happy i can show
you guys
how i would do it i'm just a passionate
individual that loves action movies
terminator
i watch this every night when i go to
sleep
check out brian frenzie's video t2
muzzle spray brian frenzy played the law
in vghs i'm being completely serious if
anybody from the john wick production
team sees this video and would like us
to do muzzle flashes for your movie i
would love to do that it would be super
cool send us an email
and so i'm starting to chop up the
original audio track and do some
creative fades so each time the gun
fires the sound in the original audio
dips this is basically what's happening
on the original audio track
that initial like spike
as i'm taking them out and replacing
them with my own punchy elements these
tails here
this is the gun
and just for reference
[Applause]
so that's where i'm at a little more
punchy yeah a little more poppy
[Music]
ready to show some vfx
here are my vfx sir
i'm really nervous about the sound
design we're more professional muzzle
flashers than we are professional sound
designers so be nice to me okay so i
haven't actually seen any of this these
are these are fresh eyeballs seeing your
muzzle flashes here okay so let's get a
refresher of the original the original
jonathan
wack
that's his face
did he detect that
wait that's actually keanu
here's our version but these are the
improved ones
[Applause]
now it's so that looks so much better
everything looks really good i'm gonna
be completely honest
i didn't really notice a difference
[Laughter]
i noticed the smoke the smoke yes made
them feel a little less like video
co-pilot tutorial
no offense to andrew
i noticed the the nice sparks coming out
of the gun too those looked really good
and just like show you guys some before
and after like here's the original john
wick
bang
here's that same shot
that looks so much better see that's the
thing about muzzle flashes in motion
it's really hard to tell the difference
but when you actually pause and look at
the flash it's very clear the sparks
look so good drawing in some fake
shadows under the wall really makes it
feel like it's an actual lighting that's
there these are such better muzzle
flashes what muzzle flashes did you guys
use what collection did you use these
are the uh pistol side desert muzzle
flashes that you filmed out in the
desert with adrian back in the day just
saying paid off speaking of weak ass
guns um i actually decided to go the
other way so
you do a special did you do
it together
it's nothing but you guys just buckle
your seat belts hold on to your pants
because we're about to get don't let me
get some big wick energy let's do it
oh god
oh my god
we don't know that there's no
firing that's such an improvement
that was a mortar round
you know joke though i feel like once
they make like the 10th john wick movie
it's actually gonna look like that yeah
cracking the lens from a bullet is like
michelangelo's movie so the wall uh when
he shoots through the wall i was like i
was like dude please blow up the whole
wall
all right well let us know what you guys
thought was this an improvement on the
original john wick do you feel like our
muzzle flashes are better or do you feel
like peter's muzzle flashes were the
best muzzle flashes that anybody could
ever make and that's what the next john
wick movie should have inside of them
also please leave a comment if there are
any other scenes you would like us to
take a look at any other movies whatever
it is please leave a comment below and
don't forget to subscribe just in case
we do it
for some reason when everyone does their
muzzle flashes it's this shape
it's either this or or the dreaded like
you know what i'm saying like it's it's
more it's more this one it's the most
common one they do it's like this
what are you doing blaming no no i'm not
done hold on i wasn't the flames oh i
like those little sparks look for this
shape in the most the old ones
there we go
hold it up right there